As television has become more serialized over
the years, major character deaths have become
increasingly commonplace.
Sometimes, however, a death is poorly planned
or executed, and it tends to stand out like
a sore thumb.
Here are some of the shows that killed characters
who should have lived.
From the very beginning, Netflix's Orange
is the New Black has had a highly-developed
sense of social justice and an admirable dedication
to in representation.
With this comedy/drama set in a women's prison,
creator Jenji Kohan and her writers have attempted
to balance a stark look at criminal justice
in America, with a dash of comedy and a cast
of likable characters, many of whom are LGBTQ
women and women of color.
One of the most likable characters from day
one was Poussey Washington, a smart and funny
black woman who ended up in prison for minor
drug charges.
Of all the women on the show, she was perhaps
the kindest and the most helpful to her fellow
inmates.
She also had some of the show's most moving
romantic storylines, from her unrequited feelings
for her best friend Taystee to her eventual
relationship with another inmate, Brooke.
"You can't live your life according to maybes."
During the show's run, the Black Lives Matter
movement was gaining steam in the real world,
reacting against the unjust deaths of black
Americans at the hands of law enforcement.
Naturally, a show as keen to promote social
justice as Orange is the New Black wanted
to reflect that reality in a story.
So in the fourth season, Poussey was accidentally
suffocated by a guard when she attempted to
diffuse an escalating situation.
Unfortunately, the show went on to attempt
to make the guard who killed her a sympathetic
character.
Fans were understandably angry and the show
became that much less lovable for the loss
of its most likable character.
In its first season, Netflix's House of Cards
was a story told from two opposing angles:
corrupt politician Frank Underwood and young
investigative reporter Zoe Barnes.
As Frank plotted and schemed to gain more
and more power, Zoe attempted to uncover the
truth about him.
Although he manipulated her for a while, and
the two even shared a creepy semi-romantic
relationship, Zoe was the first to realize
Frank had murdered Congressman Peter Russo
and wanted to see him brought to justice.
That's where Season 1 ended, and it was reasonable
to assume Season 2 would see her quest continue.
"Underwood's been using you Zoe don’t you
want to know why?"
Instead, the Season 2 premiere saw Underwood
murder Zoe by pushing her in front of a subway
train.
From that point on, House of Cards becomes
a story about the bad guys winning, and loses
all interest in featuring sympathetic protagonists.
Moreover, Frank's murder of Zoe marks his
turn from an amoral politician who'd once
killed in a moment of opportunity to a cartoonish
supervillain who could get away with anything.
The series maintained its popularity for a
while, but its story never really recovered.
Fifteen years ago, LGBTQ relationships were much less common on television than they are
today, but Buffy the Vampire Slayer offered
one of TV's earliest examples, in the romance
between Willow Rosenberg and Tara Maclay.
For a couple of years after their meeting
in Season 4, nothing could keep them apart.
Their relationship got rocky in Season 6,
but that wasn't too surprising on a show that
never shied away from a bit of soap opera-style
drama.
What was surprising was the moment later in
the season when, just as Willow and Tara had
overcome their problems and were recommitting
to their relationship, Tara was hit by a stray
bullet fired by a villain who had come looking
for Buffy.
Tara died in Willow's arms, and the rest of
the season became the story of Willow's unhinged
quest for revenge against not just the villain
in question, but the entire world.
The loss of Tara wasn't just a blow to the
show and its audience it was also an ignominious
ending to one of television's first great
lesbian relationships.
John Locke died halfway through the fifth
season of Lost, but the actor who played him,
Terry O'Quinn, was a regular on the show until
it ended.
In addition to flashbacks, Locke appeared
in the Purgatory-esque "flash sideways" scenes
during the sixth season.
However, O'Quinn also took on a new role as
the Man in Black, previously known as the
Smoke Monster, who took Locke's shape as his
primary human form after Locke's death.
"John Locke was not a believer Jack.
He was a sucker."
John Locke, with his unshakeable and sometimes
irrational faith in the power of the island,
could be an aggravating character at times,
but he was set up throughout the series as
a heroic and hugely important figure.
Then, suddenly, he died a pathetic death strangled
with an extension cord in a hotel room and
his form was used as a host for a force of
evil.
Ultimately, Locke finds peace in the afterlife,
but it was hard to watch that last season
without thinking that he deserved better.
Torchwood, an edgier spin-off of Doctor Who
about an extra-governmental agency that investigates
the supernatural, seemed to really enjoy killing
off its characters.
By the time the third season rolled around,
only three members of Torchwood remained:
Jack Harkness, Gwen Cooper, and Ianto Jones.
However, the five episodes which made up the
third season, otherwise known as Children
of Earth, had an even darker tone than the
seasons that had come before.
It was Ianto who paid the ultimate price for
that.
"I love you."
"Don't."
This upset many viewers, particularly because
Ianto was in a gay relationship with Torchwood
leader Jack Harkness.
Fans accused the series and its creators of
homophobia, despite the fact that showrunner
Russell T. Davies is himself a gay man as
is John Barrowman, who played Jack.
Nevertheless, Davies had unintentionally stumbled
into the longstanding and unfortunate cultural
trope of killing LGBTQ characters in fiction.
Lexa was the character whose death brought
criticism of what's often called the "bury
your gays" trope into mainstream discourse.
Played by Alycia Debnam-Carey on the CW sci-fi
series The 100, Lexa was the leader of a warrior
tribe on a post-apocalyptic Earth.
Drama ensued when she fell in love with Clarke,
leader of a group of delinquent teenagers
who'd been sent back to the planet by human
refugees in space.
Their political responsibilities complicated
their feelings, but they found each other
nonetheless and soon began a romantic relationship.
Unfortunately, Debnam-Carey was also one of
the stars of Fear the Walking Dead, and its
Season 2 shooting schedule interfered with
The 100.
So just as she had finally found a moment's
happiness with Clarke, Lexa was killed off.
Not only that, but she was also shot by someone
who wasn't even aiming at her exactly like
Tara on Buffy the Vampire Slayer.
The show's fan base, which included many LGBTQ
viewers, was outraged by this turn of events,
with many vowing never to watch the show again.
It became impossible to discuss The 100 without
talking about the Lexa problem, which cast
a shadow over discourse about the series until
its end.
The BBC costume drama Downton Abbey was very
much an ensemble show, but Matthew Crawley
was a principal protagonist from the very
beginning.
He's introduced as a distant cousin of patriarch
Lord Grantham, and becomes the heir to Downton
Abbey when Grantham's previous heirs die on
the Titanic.
He serves as an important audience identification
character, adjusting to life on the lavish
estate, and also engages in a doomed romance
with Mary Crawley, Grantham's daughter.
The two eventually wed and have a son, but
one day Matthew suddenly dies in an automobile
accident.
Unfortunately, there was no way Matthew could
remain on the show, because Dan Stevens wanted
to pursue a movie career and was free to leave
after Season 3's Christmas special.
However, the romance between Matthew and Mary
had been a fan-favorite aspect on the show,
and his rise to become Lord of Downton Abbey
was a central element of the series from the
very beginning.
Matthew's sudden death so totally derailed
the show's storyline that it might have been
better to just end it when Stevens left.
How I Met Your Mother was presented as a story
told by Ted Mosby to his kids, explaining
how his relationship with their mother began,
and diverging into countless stories of other
relationships along the way.
But the title character, Tracy McConnell,
doesn't really show up until the finale of
Season 8, and doesn't become a regular character
until the ninth season.
It took a long time to get there, but Ted
and Tracy's romance actually plays out pretty
well in the final season.
"Funny how sometimes you just find things."
Despite everything that had happened over
nine years, viewers were primed to watch Ted
and Tracy live happily ever after.
And then things took a turn when it was revealed
that, while Ted has been telling the story
to his kids, their mother has been dead for
six years.
She passed away from an undisclosed illness,
and Ted has been a single father ever since.
This sets up the reveal that Robin, who Ted
fell in love with in the series premiere,
is the real love of his life and the woman
he was meant to grow old with.
That might have worked better if she hadn't
spent so much of the show romantically involved
with Ted's friend Barney, who she marries
and divorces during the series finale.
The show's creators offered the defense that
this had been the plan all along, but after
such a long run it just didn't work.
The twist made Tracy feel like nothing more
than a prop, and left a very bad taste in
the mouths of viewers.
Allison Argent was a hugely important character
during the first three seasons of Teen Wolf.
She started out as the love interest of Scott
McCall, the show's lead.
Their relationship was complicated by the
fact that Allison came from a family of werewolf
hunters, while Scott was a werewolf himself.
By season 3, however, Scott and Allison's
romantic relationship was over, though they
remained friends and allies.
More importantly, actress Crystal Reed wanted
to try other things, and felt a bit stifled
as a 29-year-old actress playing a 17-year-old
character.
So she made the decision to leave the series,
and at the end of the season Allison was run
through with a sword by an Oni demon.
It was probably the right decision for Reed,
but Allison was such a strong part of the
series that Teen Wolf was never quite the
same without her.
Madison Clark was the glue that held Fear
the Walking Dead together for three whole
seasons.
The show began by focusing on her family,
as the high school guidance counselor protected
her son, daughter, husband, and stepson from
an escalating zombie apocalypse.
It was a great role for Kim Dickens, a talented
actress who rarely had a better chance to
shine, and putting a capable middle-aged woman
in the lead made Fear stand out from most
of the rugged-man-dominated zombie genre,
including the show it had spun off from.
Nevertheless, after teasing her absence for
the first few episodes of season 4, the show
revealed in a flashback that Madison had sacrificed
her life by leading a horde of zombies to
their doom while the other humans escaped.
When something like that happens to a lead
character, you might assume it's because the
actor wanted out.
This time, however, Kim Dickens was as surprised
as anyone to find out her character was dying,
and described herself as heartbroken about
the news.
New showrunners Ian Goldberg and Andrew Chambliss
claimed they wanted to kill Madison as part
of their vision for the show, but it still
seems like a strange decision to make.
Madison was what made Fear the Walking Dead
different from all the other zombie stories
out there.
So why get rid of her and become more of the
same?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.